if we look at the development of the gay
lesbian bi trans movement in the United
States the more cultural acceptance the
more cultural discourse the more media
presentation the more proximity that
people have to gain lesbian bi trans
people the more that life becomes
thinkable it becomes a cultural
possibility that one can consider
because it's already in the world you
could say that the discourse of
homosexuality as it becomes more popular
makes it more possible for people to
become gay or lesbian my sense is that
there's always something about desired
fantasy that's may be partially
unconscious or not fully realizable
although certain kinds of cultural
movements might make it possible to be
to lead a lesbian or gay life they don't
determine that they don't produce
homosexuals